see these trees
they know what's gonna happen they know
someone's going down first time I saw
mark Putnam I thought he looked like a
picture in a magazine but things go
wrong his things will those are
prescription you got a prescription for
a thousand percent that's the way the
devil comes becomes everything you've
ever wanted
I mean I solve a big case it's a bank
robber in the area
there's my lemon banks in four months
Susan helped me bring down this problem
I'd be taking a hell of a big risk big
risk a big money he waves with us we did
it didn't we we deserve her Award
the only thing that makes me miss my
legion days dad hey sweetheart
we got him congratulations
ain't nothing good gonna come away
messing around on that goddamn federal
cop there's mistakes your boyfriend's
house you come in here don't break your
[ __ ] neck why didn't you go family
needed you they'd send somebody burn
down my house last night you don't blame
me baby
I got six grand here for you I don't
want to see you anymore cuz I know way
to treat your Stark
got dinner snitch
did you go there pregnant
[Music]
you
[Applause]
you